yeah there's maybe totally reinforced
but I already knew about myself and that
is anytime someone has to hold their
breath underwater in a movie I'm holding
my brother with him on the fear like an
[ __ ] like I can totally be a spy
Mission Impossible rogue nation so
Mission Impossible rogue nation is the
fifth Mission Impossible movie usually v
installments a good indication was I
yeah you should probably just go ahead
and kill the franchise now cuz they
sucked but not mission impossible that
[ __ ] is going strong in rogue nation
Ethan Hunt is on the honchos dump but
what he knows as The Syndicate like
whispers of whether or not they actually
exist but he's going after them and you
had the CIA chasing Tom Cruise Tom
Cruise has some allies he has some
enemies are his friends with them are
they not gotta watch to find out this
movie really had it all it was a great
blend of Mission Impossible it's a great
blend of like espionage spy movie that
you know espionage spy movies are
supposed to be here like my spy gadgets
are we there yeah okay
espionage spy turn turn turn and
entertaining ass action movie they have
come together perfectly blended in
Mission Impossible rogue nation I tell
you man the action in this movie holy
[ __ ] there is a chase scene in this
movie where you're watching it you're
like this is why I love action movies
because chase sequences like that and it
has a pretty solid villain the villain
in this movie he kind of reminded me of
the Riddler he was the brains man he was
a super villain it was like Ethan Hunt
was looking at this guy he's like this
guy might be my match you're like
apparently so because this dude has Tom
Cruise spook and I love the characters
Tom Cruise the nothing more needs to be
said we all know this dude is what how
old is he was he 50 doesn't matter he's
perpetually 25 because Tom Cruise that
we have now is a cyborg what can we say
it's like the Illuminati sock Top Gun
were like we're going to keep him like
that forever but I love Simon Pegg in
this movie Simon Pegg allows them to
have comic relief without it
compromising the tension of the
Espionage moments and the thrills of the
action scenes I'm glad they use Ving
Rhames more in this movie I'm glad
Jeremy Renner has a lot of time to shine
and Alec Baldwin who's new to the series
I love his witch-hunt against Ethan Hunt
but the girl in this movie I can't think
of her name right now so I'm gonna put
it right here cuz she deserves to have
her name out there holy God this chick
was awesome she's the most badass Bond
girl you've ever seen
never seen because it's not a Bond movie
what I mean by that is usually in a spy
movie or an action movie they try to
make the girl badass but they kind of
fail because they just give her a gun
they're like well you're supposed to by
the fact that she's badass because we're
telling you but it's not enough you need
someone to actually fill the role this
girl in furiosa are like the two badass
chicks at 2015 I wouldn't mess with this
girl this girl kicked my that's not
saying much but I'm just saying she
could most certainly beat the [ __ ] out
of me in the end I was really impressed
with how Mission Impossible rogue nation
hit its mark when you can have a Mission
Impossible movie or a spy movie bond
movie whatever and you can have it have
intriguing espionage with the gadgets
and the really cool spy [ __ ] and you can
have it have really exciting action
sequences we're talking the hand-to-hand
combat was great the car chases were
great the stunts for great [ __ ] Tom
Cruise is like hanging outside of an
airplane for real you can blend these
two without one compromising the other
just perfect that's what you need in a
spy movie that's what Mission Impossible
rogue nation does guys I'm not even
gonna mince words on this I was
completely surprised by Mission
Impossible rogue nation because I'm not
gonna lie when a movie gets pushed
forward bit like that it's not it's
gonna be rushed enough it's just a smart
business decision because they didn't
want to come out parallel to Star Wars I
get that going out against Star Wars
instant death coming out in the same
summer where we got Terminator Genisys
in the same weekend we got vacation
genius and I will say Mission Impossible
rogue nation is awesome tacular
seriously though you guys do hold your
breath right I know right guys so
Mission Impossible rogue nation have you
seen it what did you think about it what
is your favorite Mission Impossible
movie thus far whatever it is whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more